good morning
everyone um
i'm jim billington librarian of congress
and i'm here to welcome you all
to the opening of the
sixth annual
national book festival which celebrates
the joys of book reading and lifelong
literacy
you're a great group to have assembled
here for the
first event
it's organized as you know by the
library of congress and you'll see the
blue shirts
all over the place and other volunteers
but it is hosted and was originated by
first lady laura bush
today 70 of america's favorite authors
in every category will
be here to read in seven pavilions and
there are four others promoting literacy
the
literature and the
literacy activity of all 50 states
but here in the history and biography
pavilion we have a stellar group of
authors starting off with doris kearns
goodwin to whom we'll turn it over in
just a moment she will be followed by
senator k bailey hutchinson
and then there'll be 10 others including
john hope franklin douglas sprinkley
it's going to be a great tent
those of you watching on c-span have a
rich experience ahead elsewhere at the
festival today we have
khaled hosseini author of the
best-selling kite runner pulitzer prize
winners geraldine brooks kyle bird and
martin sherwin
14th poet laureate
of the united states donald hall from
his farm in new hampshire
the russian poet evgeny yesterschenko
from his current teaching post in
oklahoma it's a wonderful group nba and
wnba players
children's activities visits from elmo
clifford the big red dog and other
storybook characters
and as i say reading programs from all
50 states information about the
library of congress its copyright office
our congressional program to collect
veterans war stories and our
award-winning website
loc.gov
that will attract approximately 5
billion
electronic transactions this year all of
that's in the library of congress 10.
for those stay at home stay tuned to
cspan
or log on to the special library of
congress website just for this festival
www.loc.gov
bookfest
special thanks to our sponsors to the
library's great staff and to our
dedicated
uh
and
extraordinary group of volunteers who
work all of this we definitely couldn't
do it without our sponsors
and our
volunteers and it's wonderful to see all
of you so early in the morning so it's
my pleasure to turn over
to our
to the
associate editor of book world
uh mr asim who will introduce our very
special speaker to open up the
proceedings welcome again straw seeing
the floor is here
i before i begin i'm obligated to inform
you that all sessions will be videotaped
for subsequent broadcast on the library
of congress's website and other media
the audience is encouraged to offer
comments and raise questions during the
formal question and answer period
associated with each session but please
be advised that your voice and image may
be recorded and later broadcast as part
of these proceedings by participating in
the question and answer period you are
consenting to the library's possible
reproduction and transmission of your
remarks so do not be surprised if you
see your pearly whites featured later on
television
uh my name is jabari asim i'm the deputy
editor of washington post book world and
if like me you've had the pleasure of
attending all of the national book
festival events
you know that it offers the thrill of
the new with the comfort of the familiar
i was reassured because i saw doris
kearns goodwin's presentation a few
years back she was on the same bill with
john hope franklin and it really gave me
a good feeling to discover that they
will both be here again today so that's
that's part of a wonderful afternoon
that we have to look forward to
now each of our contributors and
presenters at the book festival this
year has what you might call unique and
special gifts and about each one you
could say many things
now there are many
thinkers and writers who can comment
with clarity and authority on the events
of the day and the events of the past
and you have commentators who could
speak with equal grace on other areas
such as say unraveling the mysteries of
baseball for a lay audience
but you have very few perhaps only one
contributor today who can speak with
authority and clarity and intelligence
on both
[Applause]
we have the pleasure today of hearing ms
goodwin talk about her latest book among
other accomplishments team of rival
rivals the political genius of abraham
lincoln
about which book world had to say this
immense
finely boned book is no dull
administrative or bureaucratic history
rather
it is a story of personalities a
messianic drama if you will
please join me in extending a warm
welcome to doris kearns
goodwin thank you
it is such a great treat to be able to
talk about abraham lincoln after having
lived with him for 10 years all by
myself
i've often been asked what surprised me
the most about the lincoln who emerged
from those years of research
and i think my answer would be his
amazing personality i knew that i
respected him as a statesman i knew that
he was a person that i would feel great
admiration for but i had no idea the
affection that i would eventually feel
for him because he had this
extraordinary gift for storytelling and
a hilarious sense of humor in fact the
stories that he liked to tell are not
quite what you might expect from our
marvel monument my favorite lincoln
story had to do with the fact that when
he's told the story that ethan allen the
great revolutionary war hero went to
britain after the revolutionary war and
the british people were still upset
about losing the war so they decided to
embarrass him a little bit by putting a
picture of george washington in the
outhouse where he would have to
encounter it but he went in the outhouse
and instead of coming out angrily he
seemed to be smiling so they said well
didn't you see george washington there
oh yes he said i think it was the
perfectly appropriate place for him what
do you mean they said well he said
there's nothing to make an englishman
[ __ ] faster than the sight of general
george washington
[Applause]
[Music]
so you can imagine if lincoln told
stories like that and there were legion
of those stories before tough cabinet
meetings it would make people relax
i came to believe that early on lincoln
was aware that he possessed unusual
talents and yet it was so hard in that
bleak childhood of his to figure out how
to learn anything he later calculated he
had only gone to school one year
altogether of formal schooling a few
weeks here a few weeks there because his
father needed him to work on the farm
his father would loan him out to other
farmers to whom he owed credit but he
scoured the countryside for books and he
read everything he could lay his hands
on it was said when he got a copy of
king james bible or aesop's fables or
shakespeare's plays he was so excited he
couldn't eat he couldn't sleep the great
poet emily dickinson once said there is
no frigate like a book to take us lands
away how true for lincoln though he
never would travel to england he went
with shakespeare's kings to that merry
land he went with lord byron's poetry to
spain and portugal literature allowed
him to transcend his surroundings
but there were so many losses in his
early life that he was haunted by death
his mother died when he was nine years
old his only sister a few years later in
childbirth his first love ann rutledge
at 22
moreover when his mother died she didn't
promise him that they would meet up
again in the hereafter she simply said
to him abraham i'm going away from you
now and i shall never return
as a result he was haunted by the
thought that when our earthly life comes
to an end that's the end of us it's dust
to dust
so as he grew older he seemed to adopt a
great consolation an old greek notion
that you could live on if you
accomplished something worthy enough so
that your deeds could be told after your
life so your story could be told after
you died and i came to believe that that
huge ambition which was so much larger
than simply for office or power or
celebrity but rather as he said it the
desire to leave the world a little
better place for his having lived in it
that ambition became his lodestar it
carried him through all the early days
of his life all those difficult times it
carried him through the one significant
depression he had when he was in his
early thirties when three things had
come together to lay him low
he had broken his engagement to marry
todd lincoln not sure he was ready to
get married but knowing how much it hurt
her for his doing so his greatest friend
joshua speed the only intimate friend
he'd ever opened his heart to was
leaving illinois to go back to kentucky
and his political career was on a
downward slide
he once wrote to a friend at that time
saying he was the most miserable man
alive and his friends worried that he
was suicidal so they took all knives and
razors and scissors from his room and
his friend joshua speed came to his side
and said lincoln you must rally or you
will die he said i would just as soon
die now but i've not yet done anything
to make any human being remember that i
have lived and then he expressed this
lifelong desire to somehow accomplish
something so that his story could be
told after he died
and somehow fueled by that worthy
ambition he went back to the state
legislature he eventually won a seat in
congress he tried twice for the senate
lost twice someone else might have said
maybe you better go into another
profession but instead he kept going and
became a dark horse candidate for the
presidency on the republican ticket in
1860
everyone expected seward the governor
and senator from new york to be the
nominee the most celebrated anti-slavery
order of the time one of the founders of
the republican party if not seward they
thought it would be salmon chase the
governor and senator from ohio and if
not chase edward bates the elder
statesman of missouri but somehow
lincoln became a dark horse candidate
for that position he worked harder than
all the others unlike the others he had
not made enemies along the way
and he won that nomination stunning the
convention but then he stunned the
country even more by putting each one of
these three rivals into his cabinet it
was an unprecedented act at the time
especially since each of them thought he
should have been president instead of
lincoln they were far more experienced
far more educated far more celebrated
and somebody said to him why did you do
this he said it was very simple these
are the strongest men in the country the
country is in peril the country needs
their services but maybe lyndon johnson
would have put it more simply and more
crudely better to have your enemies
inside the tent pissing out than outside
the tent pissing in at you
now to be sure
seward chase and bates were all strong
and able men but in the end it was the
prairie lawyer from illinois who proved
the strongest of them all becoming the
undisputed captain of this unusual team
of rivals as the arc of each of his
relationships will show these people
came to respect and mire and many of
them to love him by the end of his
presidency
seward was so disappointed when he
didn't become the nominee that at first
he said as he walked around his hometown
in auburn new york he felt like he was
hearing his obituary because people were
feeling so bad about what had happened
to him when he first assumed the job of
secretary of state he thought i'll run
this thing i'll be a prime minister
he'll simply be a figurehead but within
months he came to understand that
lincoln was unlike anyone he had ever
known he settled back to give up his own
presidential ambitions the next time
around becoming lincoln's ally his
partner and indeed his most closest
friend during this period of time
lincoln loved nothing more than going to
seward's house at lafayette park they
would sit with lincoln's long legs up on
a chair and talk about everything else
except the war they went to the theater
together more than a hundred times
during his presidency lincoln loving
nothing more than to settle down in the
darkness with a shakespeare play coming
on and imagine himself back in another
time and another age seward was affable
outgoing loved good stories loved to
drink loved to smoke his cigars chase
had almost the opposite personality he
spent his evenings writing in his diary
or practicing jokes that he could never
deliver with ease always forgetting the
punchline very stiff very religious and
unlike seward he refused to give up his
own ambitions to be president indeed he
tried about five times to be president
of the united states he had this
relentless desire to be in the white
house in part i think because his own
private life had been so sad he had
married three young women all of whom
died young his first wife in childbirth
at 22 his next wife at tb of 25 his next
wife in her early 30s so that presidency
became almost an obsession with him so
much so that even in 1864 while he's
still secretary of the treasury he's
trying to organize the treasury as a
machine against lincoln saying all sorts
of mean things about lincoln lincoln
knows everything he's doing but
amazingly lincoln keeps him on the job
because he realizes that chase is doing
a fabulous job raising the loans and the
money that's necessary to keep the
troops in battle and then even more
amazingly when he finally beats chase of
course and wins the nomination and the
election in 1864 a vacancy arises in the
supreme court chief justice and he
appoints chase to this position and his
friends come to him said lincoln how can
you do that don't you know the horrible
things chase has been saying about you
he said i know meaner things that chase
has said about me than any of you do
lincoln kept in touch with everything
that was going on and he said on a
personal basis i'd rather swallow a
chair than a point chase to this post
but he will be the best man for the
rights of the emancipated slaves and
that's far more important than my
personal feelings toward him and he was
right chase served honorably in that
post lincoln was always able to have
priorities of what mattered above
everything else
now bates who becomes his attorney
general had almost the opposite arc of
life experience to chase because at
first he was very ambitious as chase was
he was in the state legislature elected
to congress but then he fell so deeply
in love with his wife julia that he said
he just couldn't bear being away from
her he wrote letters when he was on his
way to washington saying i can get
through the days okay but the nights i'm
so restless i can't bear being away from
you so finally he gave up his political
ambition so he could be with his julia
well it turned out he was with his julia
quite often because they ended up having
17 children
now when he first becomes attorney
general he thinks well lincoln's rather
unexceptional nothing famous nothing
important by the end of lincoln's
presidency he thinks lincoln is as near
a perfect man as anyone he has ever met
but in some ways the most remarkable
transformation of attitudes toward
lincoln took place between his secretary
of war stanton and lincoln they had met
as young lawyers in the 1850s stanton a
nationally celebrated lawyer lincoln
known only in illinois
and when when they met there was this
big patent case that stanton had and it
was supposed to be tried in illinois so
they thought they needed someone of
counsel in illinois interviewed lincoln
put him on the case but then the case
got transferred back to ohio they didn't
need lincoln anymore but they forgot to
tell him so he worked all summer on his
brief he was so excited he went to
cincinnati he goes right up to stanton
in his typically affable way and says
let's go up to the courthouse together
stanton took one look at lincoln and it
was recorded at the time so a big stain
on his shirt his hair was disheveled his
trousers were too short he turned to his
partner and he said we must get rid of
this long-armed ape he will hurt our
cause and our case they turned their
back on him they never opened the brief
he had painstakingly prepared lincoln
left cincinnati feeling so humiliated
that he said he never even wanted to go
back to the city again and yet amazingly
six years later when a vacancy arose in
the post of secretary of war because his
first secretary of war had resigned
everybody came to him and said lincoln
stanton's the man for the job he's blunt
he's passionate he's he's tough on
subordinates but he's brilliant lincoln
was somehow able to put this past hurt
behind him appoint him to that most
powerful civilian post and by the end of
lincoln's presidency stanton said that
he had loved him more than anyone
outside of his family
so what were the qualities really that
allowed lincoln to win all these people
over i think in part he had this
remarkable empathy for understanding
other people's points of view
he shared credit for success whenever it
came anybody's way he shouldered
responsibility for their failure he
stood up for them when things were tough
he was always able to acknowledge his
own errors and to learn from mistakes
when he was angry he had this wonderful
habit of writing a hot letter to the
person he was angry with putting it
aside hoping his emotions would cool
down and then never needing to send it
he was able to bounce back from setbacks
when they would get depressed about the
war his immediate instinct when a battle
went wrong was to go to the battlefront
so he could walk amongst the soldiers
buoying their morale visit the wounded
in the hospital
and he never forgot where he came from
he always remembered that popular
assemblage from which he had come which
meant he was a master of timing to know
when to introduce the emancipation
proclamation when to issue a public
letter to the people
all of which allowed them i think to
love him in the end and i must say it
was so sad when i had to come to the end
of the book and see that he was ready to
die that the only thing that gave me a
certain solace was finding a great
interview with the great russian writer
leo tolstoy which showed that lincoln's
desire to have his story told after he
died had truly been realized tolstoy
told of a trip he had made a couple
years earlier to a remote area of the
caucuses
and in that trip he met with a group of
wild barbarians and they asked him to
tell stories of the great men of history
so he said i told them all about
frederick the great and napoleon and
alexander
but before i finish the chief stood up
and he said but wait you haven't told us
about the greatest ruler of them all we
want to hear about that man who spoke
with the voice of thunder who laughed
like the sunrise who came from that
place called america that is so far from
here that if a young man should travel
there he would be an old man when he
arrived tell us of that man tell us of
abraham lincoln tolstoy said he was
stunned to hear that he told him
everything he knew about lincoln and
then he pondered why was it that lincoln
was so great not as great a general as
napoleon not as great a statesman as
frederick the great but tolstoy
concluded and i think generations of
historians would agree lincoln's
greatness came in the greatness of his
character and the moral fiber of his
being so i realized that all that
ambition that had carried him through
that terrible childhood all that string
of political failures and the darkest
days of the war had been realized his
story would be told after he died and to
be one of those many storytellers i am
honored to be with you today thank you
very much
thank you
and and now
thank you so much
i would be delighted to take your
questions
i'm not sure how it's working oh here's
one right here
i'm sorry i can't hear you
thank you very much
thank you yes go ahead oh microphones
that's what has to happen here go here
hi doris nice to see you um
what do you think that abraham lincoln
would have been elected today
in this environment where some of the
baggage that he carried would have been
amplified and who on the political scene
so as much as you've been able to follow
in your in-depth work
um do you think
best
reflects what he was able to do to be
able to do for us in the future oh it's
a wonderful question whether abraham
lincoln could be elected today you know
some people will will argue he probably
couldn't look at the way he looked he
had a high pitched sort of thin voice
he would have had those periods of
depression when he was younger that
people would have brought out with great
pleasure and yet on the other hand i
still believe strongly enough in the
goodwill of the american people think
about lincoln in a campaign today first
of all on point counterpoint he would
demolish the other person secondly if
you put him on jon stewart or stephen
colbert he'd be hilarious
[Laughter]
[Music]
and thirdly
he was a man who was a brilliant
politician and he understood when he won
that race in 1860 it was because he
refused to disparage his other rivals
while they were so busy disparaging one
another
and i think the real question is i mean
in today's world where the politics is
so much now it was pretty nasty back
then but it's certainly nasty today when
they go through these campaigns
when they come out of it they're less
likely i think to put their rivals into
their official cabinet because they've
been through so much together that's
pretty negative i think the real
question is whether or not there's
somebody like lincoln today i don't know
i don't see that easily on the horizon
the real question is would lincoln be
willing to run for politics today
because in his day and age politics was
the abiding passion of the time it was
the spectator sport people would come to
those debates with stephen douglas from
miles around there'd be thousands of
people listening to four-hour debates
and in the audience they would be
participating hit him again hit him
again harder so i think in some ways
politics had such a following at that
time that everybody who was something
wanted to be in it and that's what i
worry is politics our vocation today in
that same delightful way
go ahead hi i'm anne i'm a graduate
student at the college of notre dame in
baltimore
what induced you to become a writer
question is what induced me to become a
writer i'm not sure i know about the
writing part i certainly know about the
historian part i often attribute my love
of history to the days when i was only
six years old and my father taught me
that mysterious art of keeping score
while listening to baseball games so
that when he went to work in new york
during the day i could record for him
the history of that afternoon's brooklyn
dodger game now when you're only six
years old and your father comes home
every single night and i now realize
that i in excruciating detail recounted
every single play of every inning of the
game that had just taken place that
afternoon but he sat with me and made me
feel this was magical history to tell
this story of the game that afternoon it
makes you think that that's what you
want to become in fact i'm convinced i
learned the narrative art from those
nightly sessions with my father because
at first i'd be so excited i would blurt
out the dodgers one or the dodgers lost
which took much of the drama of this
two-hour telling away
so i finally learned you had to tell a
story from beginning to middle to end
much later read an essay by my heroine
barbara tuchman who said even if you're
writing about a war you have to imagine
to yourself you do not know how that war
ended so you can carry a reader with you
every step along the way so in some ways
i learned that instinctively as a kid
maybe that's where my love of writing
but it's certainly where my love of
history began
oh question over here sorry
yes um
thank you so much for your book i've
already read it and um
i thought you should have won the
pulitzer for this book so thank you very
much
um you're you just said how you learned
storytelling and you have this wonderful
part in the book where you talk of how
lincoln essentially educates himself
and
how as a young man
he um
he tells stories to the other kids
and he like memorizes things but then
kind of translates them into the
language of
how the kids can understand them can you
talk about that a little more i'd be
glad to i mean was one of the things
that so interested me to find out about
lincoln he said when he was only like
seven or eight years old
and he lived in this log cabin which was
on a road where a lot of people would
come by to go to market
and he would listen to them telling
stories with his father his father was a
good storyteller as well and he said he
couldn't sleep when he went up to his
loft at night until he could translate
the stories that he heard into language
that his own friends on the field could
then listen to the next day then he'd go
out in the field and he'd stand on a
tree stump and entertain his little
friends and i think in some ways that
became his first awareness of the
pleasure that an audience can bring but
i think it's also true that storytelling
became for him a way of dealing when you
think of oral history what it is is
connecting the past to the present and
the future and of course in the
gettysburg address he gave america the
greatest story of them all connecting
our past to the president the future and
how this new birth of freedom was going
to create a better america than the
america that they were fighting for over
here another question um
robert todd lincoln he had three
children what did he have whatever
happened to him because the lincoln
family
ended with his grandchildren
you know i don't really know all that
much about robert toddling and i've been
up to his house in hildeen and yes he
did have children but after a period of
time he had daughters and then there
were no more people to carry on the
lincoln name
so that um it's true that the lincoln
line can you imagine if we had lincoln
descendants in today's world it would be
really fun to i'd give anything to talk
to them everybody keeps teasing me what
if you could find a lincoln or abraham
and you could talk to him for five
minutes what would you ask him and i
know as an historian i'm supposed to say
what would you have done with
reconstruction the question we always
ask as historians but i think i'd simply
say to him abraham tell me a story so i
could watch him laughing his face would
come to life his life his eyes would
light up and he would laugh louder than
everybody else one more question over
here i was fascinated by your early
description of lincoln's nickname spotty
lincoln
would you enlighten us
in his what his analysis and thought was
against illegal and preemptive war
what happened is when lincoln was in the
congress he gave his maiden speech on
the mexican-american war
what had happened was he argued that
president polk had actually started the
war for reasons that he didn't tell the
public that the reasons he wanted the
war was because he wanted more territory
to come into the united states and the
president he claimed had falsely argued
that the mexicans had attacked us on our
land rather than we attacking the
mexicans and that's why he got the name
spotty lincoln because he kept saying
where is that spot of land where the
first argument came out
it was a very bold speech for a freshman
congressman to make and because the
mexican-american war was so popular
because it made so much more large the
united states lincoln was unable really
to run for congress again but it showed
even then that he had that courage that
we would see later and later in his life
i think we have time for another
question here all right that's it
thank you i'm ray danelli i'm a graduate
student at georgetown university and
thank you for coming to the book
festival my question is abraham lincoln
was active in the whig party but made
him get involved with the wic party and
at the end in 1854
when he became a republican uh why did
or how did he get involved with the wig
party why did he become a wig
okay this will be my last question
because i think it's time for the next
person to come in but i think what the
whig party represented when abraham
lincoln joined it as a young man was it
represented a hope that the government
could support on a state level at that
time they thought and eventually a
federal level
public works projects to dredge the
harbors to to create
roadways that could bring farmers
markets to the farmers products to the
market so it was sort of a pro
program and a party that looked for
upward mobility and for a young man like
lincoln who wanted opportunity for
everybody who had a chance to exercise
it the whig party seemed to represent
that but of course when the anti-slavery
issue became the major issue of the day
he became one of those founding
republicans and i think will ever ever
be honored for having become the
greatest president i think the united
states has ever had thank you very very
much
let me ask you first of all what is
different between
between the hardback edition and now the
soft cover edition the main difference
is you can hold the soft cover in bed
it's not as heavy as the hardcover
otherwise you know it's it's pretty much
the same what has this experience been
like for you now on book tour for about
a year
well you know after you spend 10 years
writing a book and you're solitarily at
home doing it it's such a great treat to
talk to the people who've read it to
tell stories about it and and i've loved
every minute of it
10 years researching abraham lincoln and
i know you're often asked the question
what you learn most about the man what
lessons can political leaders take from
lincoln's time to what we're seeing
today in america i think the kind of
public leader he was is somebody that
everybody could learn from i mean he had
the greatest empathy for understanding
where other people were coming from
listening to other people's point of
view
not disparaging his rivals being able to
share credit when success was there
shouldering responsibility for failure
acknowledging errors when he made them
you know we have so many politicians
today who seem to think they have to say
the same thing they said 20 years ago 30
years ago he would say i've changed my
mind on that i'd like to believe i'm
smarter today than i was yesterday so i
think if we had this character around
today we'd be a much better nation we'll
let you go to the book signing doris
korn's goodwin thank you very much for
joining us again so welcome it's great
to see you again
questions
is
[Music]
thank you
i'll be down there
[Applause]
[Music]